let's stick with that theme of schools
ahead of the big return to the classroom
tomorrow and we're joined by the ofsted
chief inspector amanda spellman thank
you very much for being on the programme
um i just want to start with what you've
written in the sun on sunday today
and saying it's great the school gates
will be thrown open next week but we
know the school experience won't be
normal for some time yet
testing face masks do you think that
pupils and
parents are really ready for some of the
logistical challenges
i think the vast majority are they had a
bit of a taster of this last term
um i think what we can see about the
proportion of parents who are expecting
to have their children back in school
the first possible day
shows um that people can cope do you
think that children
are going to be prepared i guess for
wearing face masks not just in communal
areas like
corridors but all day in the classroom
children are adaptable and flexible and
i think the overwhelming
um thing we're seeing is that the vast
majority of parents the vast majority
of children vast majority of teachers
are really happy
to be going back to school i think they
can live with a little bit of
inconvenience for a few weeks
i really hope um that the whole
paraphernalia of masks
and testing isn't only necessary for a
short time
i think we've got some reasons to be
optimistic from what we can see
um but let's make sure that children get
the pleasure of learning the pleasure of
socializing
and the pleasure of all those wider
activities they get when they're at
school
i was talking to gavin williamson a bit
about what happens if children
just don't wear face masks and do you
think that they need to be
enforced in the classroom or do you
think that the current approach is the
right one
face masks testing this is part of a
system of infection control that's
not designed or expected to eliminate
any infection ever happening
it's designed to reduce it um to levels
that should that
shouldn't cause anybody anxiety so
of course they're always going to be a
small proportion of children and of
adults who can't wear face masks
um but we shouldn't we we shouldn't let
anxieties about a tiny proportion
stop us recognizing um the overall goal
here
it's interesting as well to hear you
talk about how you hope that this will
be for a limited amount of time
what kind of period are you hoping that
it will last for before
some of these measures can be eased well
i think we've been told that
the face mask guidance will be reviewed
at easter i think so
i i love the idea of children being able
to come back in the summer term
able able to see everybody fully okay
now often of course began inspecting
schools again in january checks had
previously been
suspended because of covert what kind of
things
are your inspections finding well we
reported through the autumn we did
interim visits that weren't judgment
visits and we're doing monitoring visits
now
what we've seen this term has shown the
extraordinary efforts that schools have
been putting into remote education it's
been
very hard work for teachers and of
course as we know not as
nothing like as rewarding on the
receiving end so it's one of the reasons
why we should all be very happy about
getting back to school
but schools have been thinking about
what it is is the
is the the minimum curriculum they want
to make sure that children get even when
they're working remotely
a lot of effort has gone into making
sure that almost all children
are able to to reach the curriculum
through through one kind of device or
another um but it has been a slog
it's been a real slog people are
children at the receiving end are bored
lonely miserable
anxious and really really want the
normal experience again
yeah you can definitely see slog is
probably the right word there
how worried are you about the mental
health aspect of this as well you know
we talk an awful lot about
academic achievement about exams about
catch-up and progress but
it does strike me that you know it's
been very hard for
young people mentally from a mental
health perspective
and all this time at home cut off from
their friends staring at the computer
it has been very hard and i just said
that
lonely bored miserable that's very very
common but i think the good news is that
for the vast majority of children
the restoration of normality and
everyday experience of
the sense of learning being with friends
being with teachers
um getting getting to play football or
whatever it might happen to be again
that of itself for most children will be
enough
to lift those symptoms to get to to get
them back into into into being the
children um they were before and will be
again but
there is a there is a minority um let's
hope it's not too large a minority
who whose problems have increased and
it's really important that
we we're good at recognizing uh where
problems are arising things like eating
disorders things like self-harm
i know that mental health services are
very aware of the
the kinds of problems that have been
increasing and where they can expect
more more cases coming through so
everybody needs to be
alert to these the education secretary
and
gavin williamson was pretty clear that
changes to the school holidays
are on the table that they could be
looking at a five-term year potentially
or shortening the summer holiday that's
one of the things
that this review is looking into you've
written today saying making school days
longer or school holidays shorter could
backfire why do you think it could
backfire
well first of all i really want to make
sure that all children do get their
their full
full ration of schooling and we don't
want children to lose out in the long
term they're
they've been postponed to the interests
of the old and the sick while we've
dealt with coronavirus but
but children really matter and their
lives matter
um in terms of adjustments to to to
school days and school years
um many experiments have happened in the
past um i think one of the really
important things is to learn from the
experiments that have happened in the
past because
of course there's no put there's no
point adding time here or moving time
there
if you get if you don't get a
groundswell of support if children
simply don't turn up
for extra time or summer schools for
example you could end up putting a lot
of effort
into something that doesn't achieve the
objective so my concern is to make sure
that we go
with the grain of what parent parents
will embrace
um to make sure that all children get
the very most out of their education
you talk about what experiments have
shown previously
and what have they shown with with
regards to holidays
i think a number of schools have
experimented over the last couple of
decades with things like five
term years i don't think many of those
have persisted i don't know the reasons
why
um but but i think it's really important
to to learn if people and if people are
proposing
um to redesign to make sure that people
understand
um why they haven't been a long-standing
success
in the past and make make sure they're
designed in ways that people really will
throw themselves into supporting okay
and
on social media quite a few people have
contacted me with very different
experiences of home schooling and the
kind of
lessons that their classes are providing
of the sort of teacher support that
they're giving
obviously this is anecdotal but what has
your inspection
shown in terms of whether or not there
is consistency
about the amount of support schools have
provided over
over lockdown last summer when there
weren't
explicit requirements for schools it was
clear that there was enormous
variability
in the experience that children were
getting i think what our monitoring
visits this term have shown
um is that is is that we're getting much
closer
um to um consistency and in that there
are there are clear minimum expectations
of some quite significant input and that
the vast majority
of schools schools are putting that
effort in and the vast majority of
children
are receiving that having said which
there will always be corners
um whether whether problems i'm not
saying that every child in the country
has had the full experience they should
but but compared with last year
um it's a very very much better picture
but it is still tiring exhausting
draining for everybody
um i think if there's one thing we've
learned it's quite how important
schools actual schools physical schools
are for adults and for children
yeah i think that's certainly something
that parents and pupils wouldn't
disagree with you with and just finally
i know this isn't strictly your brief
but i just want to get your thoughts on
exams and do you think that having
teachers effectively deciding exam
results is the right way to go
there is no perfect solution this year
we have a system that's designed for
normal years when
all children have had more or less the
same access um to education
this year for obvious reasons it's been
very unequal
across across the country between
schools so there was a groundswell
of opinion that said that said it
wouldn't be fair simply to run exams as
normal
um because the results would recognize
that in would be as much about that
inequality and access as they would
about
um how well children have done and with
what they have been taught or what
potential they've got for progression
so we've got a hybrid here which is
i think i think is it is a good attempt
at creating
um the best we can do in in very very
unsatisfactory circumstances
and i think what what we need to do is
have everybody embrace it and do as much
as we can to make it work
okay amanda spielman thank you so much
for being on the program this morning
thank you
thank you